bind is one of the most hated maps in
valoran people just don't like playing
it not just us casuals but the pros
avoid it as well the question is why is
bind hated so much
[Music]
all right everyone before we get into
the video i gotta remind you as always
like button the subscribe button and to
ring that notification bell if you don't
big yumi will join big guoba and there's
nothing you can do about it bind some
people love it but
many others absolutely hate it with all
the burning passion you can muster
situated somewhere in robot morocco bind
is one of the four original valorem maps
with no mid two teleports and like 15
million choke points that agent cipher
calls home bind is described by the game
itself as two sites no middle gotta pick
left or right what's it gonna be then
both offer direct paths for attackers
and a pair of one-way teleporters make
it easier to flank most map designs have
a mid but bine says to heck with that
and gives you two fancy-schmancy
teleporters like it's portal 2. and just
like portal 2 you can go around and
around and around and around and
you get it if you take a gander on the
internet you will see that bind is one
of the most controversial maps valerian
has had i honestly think vine t-side is
like the worst map ever like
the way you enter your bomb side on that
map is so like i think it's brave that
especially in the meta where like people
play viper and astra and stuff like that
bro i'm so happy that you said that
because i truly think bind is one of the
worst maps ever created in a video game
everybody's ever created in video games
not in valor just in the entire
community in my mind what separates a
good or even okay map from a map that
players don't like are the opportunities
it creates and the flexibility for
players i know this may not seem like a
huge deal but let's think about other
maps for a second having someone go up
mid while you're pushing a sight or even
pushing up mid while you're attacking
can be a huge advantage on ascent or
split it's uncommon to have a five
person push because frankly it isn't the
smartest thing to do having a lurker or
someone pushing from another point
allows for that pinch during the attack
furthermore it makes you hold off the
rotators and retakers because they have
to expect that someone is waiting for
them they can't just run it down to
another site having a mid also allows
attackers to change it up instead of
this left right left right like we're in
some sort of marching drill basically
bind comes down to a binary choice are
we going a are we going b not having
that mid option creates less opportunity
for game play dignitas put it this way
bind is all about executing the perfect
push whereas maps like split and haven
focus more on your team's ability to
rotate and adapt bind will inevitably
force your team's hand on offense and
defense in the most simplistic way and
in the game like valerie where you have
asha smokes a sky dog a silva dart and a
dash to execute a site the gameplay
isn't exactly diverse okay but what
about the places you actually can push
like a short and hookah
to the most dramatically uncomfortable
places in the game you have to clear the
infinite amount of angles perfect for
rats like myself
or even while you're clearing those
angles you might find yourself on the
wrong side of an off basically
especially without smokes good flicks or
just being on the wrong side of timing
both bind bomb sites are hell to push
but have no fear attackers let's say you
need to do a quick rotation because the
clock is running down lucky for you
there are two teleporters unlucky for
you they sound like this
so technically yes you can flank and
rotate using these tele borders but you
run the risk of everyone waiting for you
once you've completed your rotation
there is no way around that god forsaken
loud sound that literally haunts my
dreams having all these angles and
quotations make bind games exhausting to
play there have been reworks
specifically with a short but it just
hasn't been enough that's why it came to
me as no surprise that in the last six
months bind has a lower attack cited win
percentage and competitive bind also was
the second least played map in the
champion stage last year beating out
fracture by two in stage one of the most
recent na qualifier it held the same
spot right above fracture it holds the
exact same spot above fracture in the
most recent stage two so it's not just
casually unenjoyable strategically it is
being avoided by the world's best teams
even with the recent rework i can only
try pushing sites so many times before i
am frustrated so this begs the question
why is the map like this for that answer
we need to look at the developers way
back in 2020. chris carney and sal
garatso speaking about the map design
process said that quote instead of
trying to create maps that all provide
an equal number of ideal combat
situations for the crazy number of
permutations we instead push each map in
a specific direction for example on bind
we ask what if we remove the middle area
of the map i.e mid which typically
provides flanking opportunities on a
traditional to objective map the intent
here is not to have a gimmick for each
map but instead to center the map around
a specific gameplay experience that we
can create with map geometry we also
evaluate new map mechanics such as
one-way teleporters or ascenders and see
how these can help us achieve this goal
ultimately where bind falls flat with
all of this is that it doesn't really
live up to what valorance sells for
their own description each map is a
playground to showcase your creative
thinking and unfortunately bind only
allows for so much creativity other maps
in pool constantly have me switching it
up and moving more bind much more often
than not literally has me sitting and
waiting until something happens i think
the word that you were looking for is
boring because this map is super super
boring if you don't have interesting
agents to play with because again
there's only a certain line of plays and
especially when the meta has been kind
of predetermined here pardon the joke
bind is binding it's limiting it is
ironic that the creativity that removed
mid from the equation added teleporters
forces its players into monotonous
cyclical work so in the end people don't
like bind because it is frustrating and
repetitive i think what ryan did with
fracture haven even ascent works because
it allows for interplay and movement
bind doesn't do that and no amount of
minor tweaks will ever make it do that
if bind is given a mid however
then
we might have a nice map on our hands
don't grip your mouse like you just
shotgunned a beer because you might end
up like me and have to wear a brace 24 7
because it hurts so bad i can't i can't
play game of hour without like
being in pain
it's not fun don't do it just stretch
you do your stretches don't grip your
mouse like this don't do it it's not
worth it